certains la qualifient d'étonnantes
d'autres de peu esthétique la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines ne laisse pas
indifférent ouverte en 1975 elle est
l'élément pionnier du centre ville de
montigny le bretonneux elle révélé
samedi son histoire dans le cadre des
journées de l'architecturé puisque
maintenant la gare un peu changé il ya
un premier bâtiment qui avait été
construit entre les voies ferrées et la
nationale 10 donc un bâtiment érigé en
1975 et qui correspond à l'ouverture de
la gare à l'époque c'est la ligne de
paris rambouillet qui s'arrête ici
dès 1975 par la suite la gare accueille
le rer c en 1980 et le
le bâtiment est complétée dans les
années qui suivent deux autres bâtiments
est en fait la volonté des aménageurs
était aussi en ouvrant sa gare en 1975
de rendre en quelque sorte
l'aménagement de la ville nouvelle
irréversible équipements multimodal la
gare rassemble chemin de fer gare
routière et vélostation la visite et en
écho à l'étude sur l'hyper centre un
réaménagement qui concerne aussi la gare
au coeur de ce projet décidée avec les
habitants j'habite le quartier saint
quentin j'ai participé aux réunions de
travail
il ya quelques mois sur la rénovation du
quartier et donc je venais voir ce que
l'on disait de l' architecture une gare
qui va changer un peu de visage dans des
prochaines années des travaux sont
engagés jusqu'en 2023 montant 43
millions d'euros